What I love about this notion of
multitasking gives people brag about how
good they are at it.
In fact,
it's a lie,
it's a lie we're telling ourselves over
and over again.
I have a friend named Janice Marturano
who is a former executive at general
mills and she now teaches meditation to
corporate executives all over America
and all over the world and she pointed
out to me,
multitasking is a computer derived term.
Computers have many processors.
We have only one processor.
We literally neurologically cannot do
more than one thing at a time.
So every time you think you're
multitasking,
essentially that's a short way of saying
you're doing many things poorly.
What I've learned to do,
and it's hard,
it's to try to do one thing at a time.
So if I'm on the phone,
I turn off my computer monitor and
actually listen radical as it may sound
to the person to whom I'm speaking.
If I'm working on a story at work,
writing a story,
I shut down my email and try to actually
focus on what I'm doing.
And what I found is that I moved through
my tasks in a much more rapid way and a
much more effective way,
and I'm doing a better job now.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
There are times when we have to
multitask.
There's no question about it.
Things get so hectic in my office,
and I'm sure in the lives of anybody
who's watching this,
we're multitasking becomes,
uh,
impossible to avoid.
I found myself walking down the hallway
the other day with a glass of water
hanging out of my mouth,
and I'm typing away on my blackberry and
walking at the same time.
So I'm a huge hypocrite on this score.
There's no question about it,
but I do my best to avoid it because I
know I do my best work when I'm only
doing one thing at a time.